David if no one saw college football
this weekend and you were going to try
to sum it up how would you sum up what
happened this weekend apocalypse I don't
know I don't know how you summon up
damage it's good crazy to think about
you always try to look for one or two
upsets and I think people pointed to
Washington USD playing great football
and that could happen but the point to
pit beating clemson and the fact i will
beating michigan after getting just
absolutely put on ten pechu a week ago
and then I think a.m. and Auburn less
surprising but just crazy and you know
two three four going down in one weekend
had been done since 1985 and those just
it was a historic weekend for sure all
right the loss that you kind of expected
with the top-ranked teams was what
Washington I think they played that they
played the best team and I think a lot
of people had a lot that they wanted to
see about Washington and I was quite
frankly they had that we talked about
Jake brownie he was number two in the
Heisman quote-unquote polls he wasn't
the number two best quarterback on the
field on Saturday and she knows about
that was a fact I mean Sam Donald was
was better than him he outplayed him
blocked on consistently just plays with
great poise as great mobility and USD
defensively I think that was the biggest
surprise I knew they would make a score
point but I didn't think their defensive
all the Washington office has been doing
whatever they wanted to and they deem
their running game useless and then shut
down Jake brownie from that point on to
how many teams have a legitimate chance
for the time for response uh from here
on in yeah i think that from here on it
I think there's four teams from the big
ten i think it's Ohio State I think it's
Michigan I think it's a stop and I think
it's Penn State I think from the big 12
you have to start looking at them now
and you have to look at oh you and you
have to look in West Virginia from the
pac-12 you got Washington you got you
tall empty see believe this or not you
got one team and that's Pamela and then
I think you got Louisville and Clemson
from the from the macc so I you Wendell
it down but I still think there's
obviously a
lot of madness in a lot of drama how do
you handle the Penn State thing that's
going to be the biggest thing I'm
looking at moving forward is if Ohio
State does beat Michigan which they have
to do to go to the college football
playoff that puts candidate in the Big
Ten title game so Penn State's going to
be looking they're going wait we won the
Big Ten hold on a minute we'd beat ohio
state are you gonna put them in over and
that's that's worth that what's going to
be nuts and i can't wait to i can't wait
to see what the committee does tuesday
night anyways because they've already
kind of opened themselves up for
criticism but we just got it we got a
fun ride with well Penn State's got
Rutgers in Michigan State left
rightfully yeah yeah that's a 1 in 13 in
conference play and those combined right
there everyone sports what ya won in 13
so it's not free they should win both of
those games out they did I don't think
Penn State the top 10 team I don't think
they're one of the top teams in the
country i think they have serious holes
on the offensive line you saw in the end
they turned the ball over four times the
first half in that game otherwise they'd
probably win but Penn State's going to
be in the equation even though remember
if you go back they lost you know 49 to
tend to Michigan they got they got these
down pretty good so does the committee
factor in having the Heisman Trophy
winner involved in this thing in and you
know with with Louisville is that is
that factoring at all this is a TV show
it's a reality show you know we can but
we can call whatever we want they want
the best teams in there that are going
to get the best ratings yeah but okay
Danny here's the thing who's to say that
what the top team is because right now
it's a crapshoot right i mean there's a
lot of options and there's a lot of
choices so why on earth would you and
this is my thought process and why
Louisville's in my top four if it's
coming down to everybody's kind of
jumbled together Alabama's separated
themselves everybody else is kind of
like okay I can point to a paw here or
there there's only one player that's the
best player in college football and
there's no denying that and that's
number eight at Louisville and so I
think when it goes out to it they play
great defense they have a great often
they have the best most explosive most
dynamic player in college football so
I'd love to see him in the Final Four
or in if they're the four season they're
taking on bama nick saban gonna be happy
I can promise you that yeah and I love
that but I I know that we want to give
the impression that we're factoring
strength of schedule margin of victory
conference everything I just wonder with
Louisville and his excitement having
it's like when michael vick was going
crazy at virginia tech man I wanted to
see him we didn't have a final four but
I wanted to see him in the mix there and
that's the way I feel about Louisville
and Lamar Jackson yeah but but again
it's only if all things are created
equal if there's a team that's above
them with a much better resume and you
can say this clear cut I'm fine with
that but to Washington van they beat
Stanford right their best winners you
thought they lost the USC okay I'm more
impressed with with Louisville beating
me break off of FSU then I am with
Washington and what I've seen and then
what I just saw against USC so I have no
problem even if Washington wins out I
have no problem if Lamar Jackson and
Louisville go in that fourth spot over a
Washington is it a down year for the SEC
or is it they're jit you know
perception-wise or is it they're just
some really they're all sort of there at
being competitive good teams or sort of
good teams and then you have one great
one I think you got one great team and
then I think everybody else is kind of
just jumbled together now I do think LSU
since a coaching change is a different
team and you saw that pin tucking game
at home with Alabama was it was super
aggressive so I think LSU's really good
but I think there's a lot of really
Arkansas for example you know Arkansas's
walk to three before this week lost the
three top 10 teams and then lost to LSU
the days were at mcp was head and
shoulders above everybody ain't Nick
isn't the case I mean not at all and you
look at the Big Ten they got four teams
that are in the playoff conversations
Phil so I mean I definitely say you can
think this you can look at as you see
and you can look at them and say that
they're not near as common as they used
to be before I let you go game day will
be at Western Michigan let people behind
the curtain here of you know do you have
how do you come up with a Western
Michigan as opposed to I don't know pick
another spot of West Virginia
okay West Virginia Oklahoma which would
be an awesome awesome scene well first
of all Dan it to be perfectly clear I
don't have to say anything i I don't I
don't control has anybody ever ask you
your opinion David on where colors no
why would I asked my opinion I'm the
last guy probably on the game Dave said
they would they would have any say in
any of that definitely the least tenured
so who has veto who has veto power if I
said Herbie or rece Davis 90 Fowler
handsome veto power but yeah if Herbie
or rece Davis said we're not going or we
are going who carries the most weight uh
who carries them I'm gonna leave that
there for some to number four at the end
of the session in your step you know
what it kind of cool day when we do this
last year we did you know James Madison
and that was that was the most memorable
stop along the way last year we did
North Dakota State year before the most
memorable stop along the way it is
really cool for us because Alabama's
kind of like oh like you're supposed to
be here dude like we're the king of the
crop like yeah y'all come to us and when
you have a team like like Western
Michigan who's got a great season a
superstar coach in the making with Fleck
I think they accept you a lot more a lot
more fun they're excited the adrenaline
going there'll be a crazy turnout so
these are fun but to be clear I have
zero say in anything to do Western
Michigan's turnout is going to be
unbelievable and that's why when you
bring up north dakota state or james
madison they realize it's a one and done
you may never get back there again your
opportunity to go out have fun show your
school colors bring a signer to know so
i'm sure that they're gonna they're
going to do a great great job what's the
one crowd where you got a little nervous
oh the one crowd um I'll say this I took
my son with me a couple weeks ago to LSU
cuz he died I take him with me every
other week if I can my wife obviously
won't let me check him out of school
every Friday but I'm like forget school
anyways that's a sadness so I took I
took them to LSU and that was
we the gift to me the the most vulgar
crowd like you get you got a guy in the
front just with sign saying I'm going
back to prison and yelling curse words
and just I mean it's just it's a crazy
crazy atmosphere and crazy things happen
in Baton Rouge so that's one of the sort
of the scary were you worried for your
life a little bit on what's coming up on
the set yeah then your son comes home he
has new words to tell mom all about that
he learned in Baton Rouge yeah and that
gives me a good cancer brain in the next
week right hey David great to talk to
you again safe travels thanks for
joining us i preciate that that's a
david [ __ ] the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience